welcome to you now you're calling for
this new testing regime
at airports how would it work well it
would
be a two-stage test so on arrival you
would be tested to see whether you had
covered
if you are clear of covid you would then
go into quarantine as you normally would
you'd give all your details for
tracking and testing and tracing and
then after either five or eight days
you'd have a second test
if that came up clean then you would be
allowed out of quarantine early
so that would save um five six seven
days
of quarantine which would be a huge
benefit for
people who are coming back from spain
last week who suddenly got caught
caught out by this quarantined roulette
would you be able to introduce something
like this relatively quickly at heathrow
would you be geared up for it
yes we could we've been planning ahead
and we've been working with swiss ball
collinson on how this would work for the
last four weeks
we are we pushed the button over the
weekend on setting up a testing facility
in terminal 2.
we can have it up and running within the
next two weeks what we need though
is for the government to work with us on
this
we need them to allow people out of
quarantine if they have tested
clear at both of those testing points
we need them to work with us on making
sure we tie into their track and trace
system and i'm sure there'll be some
other changes that we need to make to
fit in with government policy but this
is an opportunity for government
and the driver sector to work together
to
save the economy um but also prevent a
second wave of covid
john wouldn't this involve travelers
having to hang around at the airport
though once they'd arrived how long
would they have to do so
well they'd only be there for the uh the
test itself and then they get the
results after they have gone to
their place of quarantine so they don't
need to hang around for very long
and bear in mind this is only for
passengers coming in from
lead countries and there are very few of
those at all at the moment
about a third of our usual markets are
considered amber and green
and uh people are allowed to travel
freely to those but the
the balance 70 of all of our markets are
considered red
very few people are flying from those
countries and only those people who want
to have the
test as an alternative to quarantine and
are prepared to pay for the test and it
is 150 pounds so it's not cheap at the
moment
but those people would volunteer to go
through a test
as a way of exiting quarantine quicker
now countries like france and germany
are already doing this
at their airports is there much evidence
of it uh being successful
oh yes and and in fact places like
france have
taken a a less conservative approach
than we are proposing here
in the uk so they started their trials
at the beginning of june
um with overseas dependent territories
they
initially had a test on departure and on
the rival
and then when they found that they were
getting consistent results at both ends
they dropped the test on the arrival and
now just rely on a single
test before departure now that sounds
like a
a fantastic solution but we completely
understand that that's not
something that the uk government is
prepared to do
at this stage because a single test is
not good enough
to tell whether somebody is contagious
so that's why we're supporting a a
double test
uh either first day and fifth day or
first day and eighth day
so that we can make sure that we are not
re-importing covid
um while allowing people to get out of
quarantine quicker what would be the
consequences to your business john i
mean you've outlined some pretty
horrendous financial results today of
the government not going ahead with
something like this i mean the industry
just can't limp on like this can it
no and for us as a business we've lost
half a billion pounds in the first
half of this year so it's a devastating
impact fortunately we are well funded
we're investment grade credit rating
we have enough cash to see us through to
the end of 2022 so we're
we're very well placed but not everyone
in the aviation sector is in
that position and we will see more
companies going to the wall
and more job losses as a result of uh
keeping
britain locked down for the foreseeable
future so we do need to see a path
through
the government's already done some good
things by introducing this risk-based
approach with the
green amber red approach what we now
need to do is to have a solution for red
countries that will get people flying
and where this matters increasingly will
be on finding a way for people to be
able to travel between the uk
and places like canada and singapore the
us
india key trading markets that we need
to be exporting to
that we need to get tourists from over
the coming year and unless we have a way
of allowing people to travel more
freely to those markets then the uk
economy is really going to struggle
we've already seen millions of job
losses being announced i'm doing my best
to avoid compulsory job losses
at heathrow but it's really difficult
but we all want
to keep people safe but also keep people
in work
john how badly has confidence in the
government been shaken by
its rather arbitrary imposition of these
quarantine rules on
travelers from spain and in particular
the spanish islands
well i actually i think the government
has a really difficult job to do and
only they can make the judgment between
uh keeping people safe and keeping the
economy moving and
helping people get on their holidays
it's an impossible decision to make and
we don't have all the information they
need
so i i can't criticize the government
over what they have
chosen to do what i do want to do though
is make sure this doesn't happen again
by having an alternative to blanky
quarantine passengers will
understandably feel that they're playing
quarantine roulette uh when they go on
holiday
and don't know whether they'll they'll
be quarantined when they return or not
we need to have doing this and and
we we don't know you said john you say
that the german government
has been rather more forensic in how
it's imposed quarantine regulation so if
you take spain they've the german
government has imposed it on catalonia
on aragon but not on the spanish islands
and i i think uh that kind of regional
approach does seem to make sense when
you think about the first wave of kovid
entire countries were locked down and
the response from other countries was to
close off entire countries
the second wave response is much more
targeted it's individual cities that are
being locked down
and that suggests we should have a much
more targeted approach to
quarantine so people coming from
barcelona we clearly
we want to quarantine or test them the
people coming from the canary islands
it's hard to see why they would be
treated as if they were coming from
barcelona
and when you think about a country the
size of the united states that's an
entire continent
why are we treating new york the way
that we might treat
miami or texas we need to have a more
targeted a more sophisticated way of
opening our borders so that we keep
people safe but
we allowed to allow people to get back
to work in as normal a way as possible
we're going to be living this with this
for a long time and if our
response is to close down our country as
a small island trading nation
we will kill our economy and millions of
jobs will be lost that could have been
saved
and that's why we want to work with the
government to get this
alternative to quarantine the red
countries up and running as fast as
possible
john if you'd be so kind briefly please
you mentioned that you're resisting
uh compulsory redundancies for how much
longer can you do this if things
continue in this vein
well we're coming to the end of our
negotiations with the unions we've
already
had a voluntary severance scheme for
frontline colleagues and about uh
850 frontline colleagues have chosen to
leave
and and we've we've looked after them
well uh in doing so
but if we get to the right conclusion
with the unions we can avoid
compulsory job losses while getting our
costs down
but it's as simple as a trade-off
between paying people less than we used
to particularly if they were on
legacy terms way above market rates
paying those people a bit less to get
them back onto market terms
if we don't do that we're going to have
to look at compulsory job losses